[Music]
if I close this deal I'll be the first
left woman to be a VP in the company
hi mom hey listen it's your sister
she's gay now if you could pick her up
I'd appreciate it what time what time
honey it's Jail you get it when you can
like the songs they don't smell like
roaches in here and I need a job
won't you just work here what you want
to put plenty you don't know what she
want okay you could just stand right
there and think about it who is this
Charlie Charlie he is an amazing guy she
met him online a year ago but she's
never even seen him he seemed too good
to be true
if a man looks too good to be true here
you're being catfished
anybody we need to go and find this son
of a [ __ ] you catfished it and we gonna
tear his ass up this should be good
[Music]
there are like that is a dress we're
gonna do this tonight we don't need a
saw some plastic burner phone I can't
even that's good you need to go ahead
and let all the liquids out cuz you
don't want to leave no DNA
you're not helping every time you try to
kill the man you're gonna squirt a
little Pete I know that for sure this
connection is so wrecking it hello what
mama you in the window I'm sorry what we
nah don't know cell phone line I can't
hear you baby I can't hear
[Music]
you